here comes Kendra Sunderland here who's
just librarian from the 60s hi Kendra
how are you welcome Kendra waiting she's
coming up oh she's here
okay we don't had you in a while yeah
that was you got used to doing adult
films uh yeah I just stopped shooting
professionally but I do my own stuff
why'd you stop shooting professionally
because I mean it's just more money to
do your own stuff than it is to like
shoot so Kendra made a name for herself
of course masturbating in her college
library oh that's right she masturbated
on a webcam in her college library and
everything was cool except then you
posted it on pornhub right there's
somebody else did or somebody posted oh
and then the college found out and then
you got like you didn't get arrested but
you got the cops came right yeah I think
watching public indecency okay so they
kicked your school I mean technically I
wasn't like enrolled but I'm not allowed
on campus groans what could you phone
your vagina in the library yeah they'll
do it Oregon State University of the
Beavers oh yeah
do you miss it no I don't miss school
you make more money now yeah definitely
I don't miss being broke at all what did
you want to do when you want I wanted to
be like a troubled teens counselor why
are your trouble team that's always what
becomes troubled teen counselors that
people are [ __ ] yeah I mean I wasn't
super [ __ ] up but you know enough that
you want to help people I did and I was
like I don't want to listen to people's
problems all day you said at one point
and it was like maybe a year or two ago
that you were leaving to go back to
school for animal science right yeah did
you end up doing that no I kind of
decided to wait till I'm like old and I
have nothing else to do I see I see yeah
there is there is a window on this adult
entertainment portion of your life right
yeah so wait until that window closes
then you can then you can get into your
animal sciences that's what I'm trying
to tell you Joe well yeah I mean I still
look good I mean the part in the prime
of my life but I haven't decided to
start making films yet
you ever use these I forgot you were
promoting this Laney just handed it to
us so do you want to describe why it's a
toy for men molded from my lady parts
Wow
I've used to fly bought a flashlight
because I'm so I'm so [ __ ] up sexually
I'm like I just wanted to you know and I
got one it wasn't bad yeah but you used
it like a like flashlights and other
things no it's always helpful it's in
the shape of a flashlight but it's
actually it's a portable vagina that you
can put your penis and now I get it yeah
see it's one size fit all you do this do
you own this or they do it they God will
give you just money to do it though do
you get like a percentage of how many of
these are sold I get a percentage so
everybody go buy your fleshly you get
royalties on your vagina yes I do
that's incredible how do they how do
they mold one of these things just
spread your legs and they put the like
goopy stuff on you and then then this
stuff like plaster like fruit when you
like break your arm or something and
then they just like how long does it
take it just sits for like 20 minutes or
so it's really interesting it feels like
warm sometimes and cold and then like
when they peel it off it feels really
good
does it go inside though no it might at
the inside of my vagina I hope doesn't
look like all those bumps and everything
textured on the inside for feel have you
ever used the flashlight no Joe why are
you surprised I just figure is it right
now in front of me am I the only one
here who's used a flashlight you did of
course do you like them he's better than
nothing
yeah you know mahendra sunderland
flashlight it's better than nothing see
I mean I know what these cost but a
butter roll is only like two dollars
or that body we know you're not eating
this you've never used a flashlight
Richemont no they do feel pretty good
for me to jerk off you know it takes so
much to get hard right you know and I'm
not gonna waste a blue pill on an
inanimate object you know what I mean
sir I deal with my wife you know but you
know so you don't jerk off at all oh
yeah but it takes you know what I mean
I've come and I've come and I've been
soft and I am so disappointed with
myself that I'm not even hard and
there's nothing worse than the jerking
off soft and coming like you're bullying
your dish like all right let me get this
over with it's so you're apologizing to
yourself like you're shaking an involute
or a mouthful of water is this sexy
Kendra you can yeah sometimes it's just
theory or fact we have half the rooms
they know empirically it is possible
I've jerked off a lot but I was in
Hornet my therapist told me I have a
rata size rage which is when you worship
which is when you're angry and you try
to make it like it's just sexual moment
just to kind of get beyond that feeling
right I make it sexual I've run out of
things to think about
jerking off I mean that's why the flesh
light comes in to challenge myself and
just like look at a wall I do it
a guy I know will put your mouth it was
a heroin he should get those government
blocks of cheese and cut a hole in them
put him in a microwave get it a little
warm and [ __ ] it right well he put one
in the microwave with a hole in it then
forgot about it next day took it to the
pawn shop to sell it and the guy
[Laughter]
spanking one out in the library got you
all an empire you know what I mean yeah
I do you remember when you spanked me
actually speaking of spanking did I
spank you I vaguely remember I haven't
done it in a while I just shot my sister
and her husband because we're they're
like looking on Netflix for specials and
I was like wait I mean I've been
interviewed by that guy for I was like
oh yeah he spanks me and they pulled up
the video you seen some weird [ __ ] I got
spanked in the beginning of that video
Netflix oh it's ironic I've done a few
things you're saying weird [ __ ] though
is that when was that chip maybe chips
remember I'm a pretty good dirty talk
yeah boyfriend you have no people guys
what happen aided to be with a girl
that's you know well and she said not
anymore did she break up yeah yeah a few
months ago Oh what happened I just
decided I'd be better off on my own I
think it was in the business that I
really want to live that whole life and
I don't think we can do it you know I
told him I'm hanging up my friends was
the last straw so oh okay that does he
was hitting on your friend yeah but way
you dizzy was he in the business do you
have sex with other people or no I mean
we both did but he's a photographer for
the business now and he's like behind
the camera so would you get jealous if
he slept to other people I mean I would
because I mean he was allowed to like go
to parties and do whatever and like hook
up with girls and my side of it was work
it's like me hooking up what other
people's work which is completely
different and it's like
it's still sex but it's like it's a
completely different things like use the
argument Jo right girls in the business
say that even though you're right it is
work it's different but it's still
[ __ ] it's like it still feels good on
some level I mean nobody doesn't want to
[ __ ] Manuel Ferraro that's not exactly a
bad day at work for most girls if you're
dating someone in the business you gotta
be able to [ __ ] I mean I'm not I'm not I
don't think anybody in the room who's
Manuel Ferrari she's a big horse well
he's one that women he's one that women
love there's no woman that's [ __ ] him
and going oh no I gotta [ __ ] this guy
what's the great event Manuel Ferrara is
a nice day and he dirty talks like a lot
I'm just like he'll just go non-stop in
your ear and like just say anything does
he maintain his erections yes it'll
don't feel like a race traitor when you
sleep with black eyes in the mirror so
you do your own your own films now yeah
when did you start that I'm just a few
months ago I just try and do it in
between traveling I'm near the end of
traveling for like months and months so
what are you traveling for just work
I've been traveling non-stop for the
past like two three months the only time
I didn't get to travel is and I spent a
night in jail so why would what did you
go to jail how much is a bunch of weed
uh well like the thing is like I knew I
had edibles and bait pens and joints I
didn't know I was like I know I don't
know I had like containers of weed so I
had like big containers and weed smaller
containers like nine small joints dipped
in oil and key three bigger ones nine
regular joints how high do you need to
be you just get high maybe like every
now and then I was gone for ten days so
it was very clear I'm just a very heavy
starter but they're trying to get me
with transporting and intent to sell oh
well any of it no no I was going here I
was supposed to come here and do this
that's why I had to reschedule all this
so you couldn't just buy it here well
it's not really the same I don't know if
you guys have ever been to the west
coast but it's a lot more simple where
you can just walk into a store and get
whatever you want
yes yeah right here you got to go
through a dealer like it's usually they
arrested you and they put your nail when
they spend 12 hours in South Central
it's pretty hard
well how did the how did the people you
were with take to you oh they're cool
that was one Mexican lady in there that
told me I was mad sexy you know okay you
they have sex in here you should see me
out there like this is nothing that's
great yeah when they stopped your bag
like when the bags went through and they
stopped it they're like wait let's look
through this one is that the moment
where you go like maybe you won't notice
all of it and then you found one thing
and then it was like one thing after the
other he's looking at it yet that's we
yep yeah they took like my CV DT HC like
pain rub like they literally wiped me
clean and my police report was so I'm
gonna put this in Joe's carry on for ya
I'm not gonna be a felon which you know
good but it was kind of cool when I was
a non convicted felon what'd you pay us
we're gonna pay a fine not yet I think
she's gonna try and like keep it open
for a year and as long as I don't get in
any more trouble than it's good okay so
you didn't bring any this time good
lawyer talk okay you probably you don't
need to probably announcing that is what
I don't care about we you don't want to
fly with it you shouldn't bring it on
planes it's just too too much you know
just get where you go especially when
you need an entire carry-on dedicated
she was trying to give her lessons
Ritchie's just don't bring it on a
[ __ ] plane I don't care somebody gets
high vintage medical you can bring
medical medical in in New York it's like
because I was flying to a state where
it's not legal and also not only go on a
federal level so in airports I think
that ready hi now huh are you high now
no it's just early in the morning oh you
do any anything else like Cokin know
what is
what's freebase that's how I ever miss
it no I don't miss our free be more
interesting than you talking about your
steps
[Laughter]
cocaine explain to explain for
freebasing to Kendra like how do you
make it know that many different ways
soda ammonia ether but you don't want to
get involved in that no in your life
what are you you still talk to your
parents I'm lucky because my parents are
like the best and they're super
supportive and I told my dad I was doing
porn and he said he loved me no matter
what and did you send them at one of the
flashlights no like mama I made it like
you know oh I mean I did tell her like
that you know I told her I didn't send
them one but I just like I should send
them one and say look mom and dad you
made this vagina and now everybody gets
a little version yeah yeah forever
spectacular you happy with how it came
out I'm a little there's one thing on
the box I'm not happy and it was my
favorite sex act and they said
missionary which makes me sound so
boring I'm like good old Mitch's my
favorite your favorite no I would have
said [ __ ] like giving [ __ ] is my
favorite yeah that's the perfect girl
let me ask you let me ask you Kendra do
you say things like giving [ __ ] is
my favorite sexual position because then
more guys will buy the the flashlight
exactly like oh that's very exciting I
mean I wish they would
with that on the box wait you can come
wall going down on the guy I'm joking I
love that [ __ ] I love that [ __ ]
she's talking about having her a seat
what color's your well that was the
least pertinent to what she was saying
she was arrested for possible don't fly
what suck a dick but there's another to
the show by the way by the way right
after Jim said did the pot thing you
said don't do freebase it'll ruin your
life Gillian yeah is pretty good I've
not used it a lot I don't like toys but
that's the only one I've used as I've
enjoyed there's a flashlight was just
[ __ ] that and you jerk off with it
like a sleeve of shower mounts or like
mounts you can put on the walls pretty
heavy and you can put it on your iPad
now they have like an iPad like porn on
your iPad Wow
you know they've thought of everything
yeah yeah you feel shame after you jack
off I can't imagine like yeah like
dismount a whole system yeah I might or
might not have just gone in the now
I might or might not have just thought
of the visual of Joe Mackey [ __ ] the
shower wall and seeing Joe humping the
shower wall because this life is
connected to it yeah
that Joe uh y'all do i you never [ __ ]
shower wall no I've never done me I
didn't even know these were things in 20
minutes ago
you thinking about it now well I see
that speed in America and Spain yeah
they have to ship it and that's that's
good you think about the economic
matters oh I see I'm out too behind a
glory hole - why you looking at me like
that do you end up meeting guys that are
bashful like like Joe Mackey is yeah a
lot of times they're like super cute you
like that I think it's cute I'm not
bashful though I'm as comfortable as a
quality-control the person had a
waterbed factor I'm pretty suave what
would you do to like make somebody like
Joe feel comfortable not like fit but
just like in terms of the vibe yeah I
probably just don't know I'm just like a
regular girl so I'm to be nervous hear
that Joe yeah yeah she doesn't bite well
I mean no you want me to Joe well I
don't like it when people bite me Joe is
I've heard Josie I can't come unless my
tits are bit specially made fairness
it's a good coach for me you're not
lying we're talking about mounting
penises talk about my children yeah I
gotta get my daughter okay Wow shy is an
attractive quality of some woman is it
do you find shyness a trait or do you
need guys to be aggressive I mean I find
shyness to be cute and adorable but I
mean for a guy that I really want to
like be with I want them to be like so
like Joe's the type of guy that you'd be
like oh he's so cute he's so cute and
then some aggressive guy comes over and
just takes you
away from him hello guys yeah just like
take their shirt off if he was coughing
enough to do it like right in this
studio if we chant his name like Vic
Morrow okay was it just because you got
horny or you knew it was can you ask any
American I know something but it was
only like my second day of webcamming
and they told me I make more money and
have more viewers if I went someplace
public so I literally just packed up and
went to the library not how do people
know he wants that library did someone
recognize the books yeah I think it was
like one of the frat guys I guess found
it and hosted it oh okay
did you want to see the video is that
what you were no no Sophie never been to
a library you probably haven't that's
very similar to any library Joe are you
trying to imply that I'm not a well-read
man Oh mister UFC people are fighting
each other in octagons that's so smart
do you get at any point do you get
aggressive like Kendra was just talking
about you know women sometimes like a
guy who's aggressive not just kind of
cute well I your cuteness is off the you
know it's off the charts I can be pretty
tough yeah if he get on my bad side
Becky
once nearly fight a guy at the
playwright tavern really well I had no
interaction with spilled a beer on me
when I was walking down the steps you
ran after me so I pushed him and then I
locked the door there's a door that
locks Matthew just threw him locks the
door and the guy couldn't get back in is
that kind of sexy Kendra yeah see ya
yeah why did I spill a beer on you I
don't know he's build it or just
accidentally knots there's two floors to
that bar and I was walking down the
steps T just got crazy ran down the
stairs I know interaction what did you
see your set oh maybe he just gets
really angry when I
is really funny and talented so could be
that's what happened now you're now get
to your mean side how long does that
take huh oh I mean like say there's say
there's like two guys trying to mug an
old lady I'll tap a keg of whup-ass on
you will you tap that can't go up ass at
a moment's notice
I'll beat up those criminals that's
right I don't care if they call me a
foul I'm still voting your first arrest
I mean technically the I mean the
library right technically I didn't get
arrested like handcuffed and put in the
back of a police car so it's my time my
first time doing that and being in jail
they did copyright yeah yeah are you
crying
yeah what would like when did you
realize like oh no I'm not getting on
this plane when I was like what happens
if I miss my flight and the guy was like
oh what time is your flight and he's
like oh yeah you're definitely missing
it but then I was like as soon as they
saw everything that I had they're like
all right you're getting arrested and
they're like do you know why no like
yeah and then I got they're like oh we
have to handcuff you and take you down
and I was like can I just go like I
promise I'll just go on my own like I
don't want to be handcuffed and taken
out of here and they had to you had to
know though that like it wasn't you're
probably gonna be out soon I mean just a
little bit of pot well yeah to South
Central at 3 a.m. I got put so and I was
just like and then I guess they serve
breakfast at 4 a.m. so I was like I
literally laid down and then two seconds
later they're like oh turn the lights on
for breakfast and what was the breakfast
good
I didn't eat for TMZ whatsoever in there
it was gross that seems a little early
for prison breakfast court dates they
probably four times I don't know I was
just weird
all hours to do in there asleep was any
waffles yeah I guess we're nervous to
sleep though with all those other people
and then oh no they were chill they're
like really cool but I was just like I
just was irritated because I just need
to call somebody like I was like I have
money I just need to use the phone and
they wouldn't let me do it for like 12
hours and then a phone call well because
there's just 3 a.m. and they're like oh
you can't after lunch and then after
lunch was like you can in an hour and
then when I finally got to use the phone
then it was like everyone figured out
where I was and was trying to get me out
oh you're alone yeah oh yeah that's kind
of crazy if you're traveling by yourself
and you just have to sit there for 12
hours that means you're you never get on
your flight you just but you don't have
your phone you're not texting anybody
I wonder where Kendra is or they just
don't freaking notice and my friend I
was like I literally had my location on
with you for things like this like she
couldn't figure out where I was and she
didn't think to check my location so if
I ever get kidnapped I'm like so screwed
I my friends TMZ there when you know
we're getting arrested their way was TMZ
there no no thankfully so were you
worried if you became a felon you
wouldn't be able to vote no I was more
so worried about not being able to fly
with wheat that would be tough yeah for
a vape pen no well if it's a vape pen
and also edibles and also only the
containers of weed I didn't know I had
these big containers and the oil is okay
to travel or anything else is fine I
traveled with all those things before in
my purse like joints and everything it's
fine it was just the containers I didn't
know they were in there yeah better off
just buying it when you arrive there's
got to be a place together
yeah really what type of container was
like Country Crock or was it like a
small film key I don't know we obviously
don't smoke really make you feel like an
outsider I just it's like one of those
anti-drug commercials from the 80s where
they're like you're I'm not a chicken
you're a turkey that's right just
thinking of those Ninja Turtles yeah oh
my god was that the commercial yeah it
was it was always like the kid who
didn't do drugs got the upper
and with his witty comeback it was never
that way yeah that's the one where I was
like is like what are you chicken and
then he goes I'm not a chicken you're a
turkey yeah and then the drug dealers
like I clock
he couldn't recover from that now the
one with a kid like eight his hand like
it seemed like a good idea at the time
he couldn't get his hand out of his
mouth that's when the Ninja Turtles come
up and they go drug dealers or dorks
don't even talk to him Michelangelo
loves to party and pizza now
Michelangelo he's eating all those pizza
slices in a month oh yeah I don't think
I've ever hated anybody more neck Kendra
when you're when you're looking for guys
to date or hanging out with or whatever
if you find out a guy doesn't smoke at
all is that like we're not gonna get
along or is that fine it's not a
deal-breaker but it's just like uh you
know just kind of awkward cuz then I
feel like I'm just like irritating them
with my smell like we dance you know I
kind of just look for a guy that I can
smoke with like that's always a plus
that's a shame so that's two strikes Joe
Sierra smokes a lot of drugs drugs this
guy you like drugs Sam Moreau I don't
really smoke much I smoke a little CBD
for my back but I back problems but I
don't know I drink it it's this stuff I
can't plan that doesn't have like a lot
of psychological effect on you it's
mostly just for a pain and like a lot of
people just take CBD tincture like CBD
edibles or anything just for pain I
smoked it when I'm with Joe usually no
maybe no I'm I like alcohol more I'm not
really a big smoker like to drink Kendra
no like the opposite I see my mom and my
sister like I can't my mom can outdrink
me like that's how much I don't like to
drink was your mom an alcoholic right no
she could just drink would you grow up
Salem Oregon better your parents still
there yeah that's nice that's where
Kolby summons for tales from the Lord
and tonight's a nice place yeah but
aren't you kind of old
Salem's the capital that's where you
would that's where they would vote on
the laws if you can you're not a felon
[Laughter]
for that guy who's that guy in West
Virginia you can turn on by guys who are
kind of their expertise is local
government you like that I was trying to
help Sam how but he blew it hey we
should like drunks I love drugs
I smoke lots of drugs sell organic when
you say that huh
thank you Sam is funny single ridges
again coming off like an old lady
Sam go on a date I would love it I was
thinking the same thing that's not it's
not Sam though me waiting for rich to
pinch my cheeks I leave Sunday so many
times it's funny he DV access TV live
I've jacked off in lots of libraries
okay we used to do that was just IMing a
baby
Telly Savalas
we got a video sent to us that Kendra
might be able to shed some expertise on
yes it's have you you know extreme
smothering no extreme smothering yeah
I'm on the phone she be able to hear it
this sound isn't too too important
you'll be able I think you'll be able to
pick up on it
Joe Mackey said a road trip Hey Joe
Mackey sent me this from his cell phone
actually Joe is tied to the bed I have
Matt in this video you could look like a
cheap motel that's right yeah well you
get see stole the the the blanket from
the motel that's his bedroom Sam Roberts
is a dirty lawyer this is and there's a
guy in his back tie just head on a
pillow Joe Joe there's some there's some
foreshadowing in this large lady I feel
like I know how this one ends Yeah right
to the guys show with a hearse we see
some big big thick thighs yeah right
over his chest and his head is on the
pillow and his arms are tied almost like
I like a crucifix yeah you know it's not
Norton because there's no poop coming in
like [ __ ] when you're clean unless she
did a wrestling thing stopped it with
her but I don't know I'll tell you that
that website domain name is misleading
WorldStarHipHop so she jumped down I
don't get that she jumped up on the air
landed on his face with her ass cheeks
he's tied oh and she leaves it there he
can't say the same for he's tapping on
and she just rubs her ass cheeks and ass
crack on his face that would make me so
claustrophobic is staying in it's right
by the elevator that would make me so
claustrophobic I would say I've been
smothered before for a second like we
are
but to not be able to get a nice loooong
yeah no [ __ ] that
no but I guess some people like that
like the danger in the oh my like I
can't breathe that died during S&M
sessions who get like tied up or they
have [ __ ] like saran wrap put on
their bodies and they like just like the
[ __ ] air hole put in their mouth like
for it to breathe - it's crazy [ __ ]
you know people like wrapped around and
Kendra's up promoting Kendra so it's
pretty ugly sorry I was promoting the
her flesh light and she's stunning and
the flashlight it really has a decent
piece of sexual equip ease of equipment
yeah I've actually was looking for mine
not long Hey it helps you to bring that
one home no I mean she's using it to
promote but I've used it for you I want
one thank you yeah are you should bring
bags Jim unfortunately does not give off
that creepy vibe otherwise no I know I
gotta go do the UFC potty I can't bring
that into the [ __ ] room I don't know
no you open up that Sarah to a whole new
world does it take batteries no it's not
a vibrator you're supposed to [ __ ] it
don't put it up your ass do you ever do
you ever have guys when you end up
meeting guys do they have weird requests
because you know you're in the industry
you're so sexually out there I mean not
a lot of people that I am me but like it
you know it happens
yeah what's a weird request that
somebody would give you I mean a lot of
people like just I don't know I guess
things with feet like they want me to
like spit in my shoes really that's
weird
how many nine nine okay boy that
flashlight I don't have a huge foot
fetish but I mean I do like the larger
feet yeah yeah yeah do you hear what
Kendra said what she said you know what
that means I don't my headliner rich
upon us do you think do you think Joe
Mackey's got an impressive Anatomy I
miss dick I think Joe his Joe Joe I'm
gonna guess Joe his dick is six by six
[Laughter]
squared circle oh yeah I think it's
probably very girthy with a tapered
small head all right
that's not happy this is our design no I
know but a pile of field witch doctor
attacked his dick fat little basin is
the head for small do you take it get
Kendra when you I know Lanie over there
is a big-time Packer checker she loves
it I was in Polish look she loves
looking a bulging crotch watch watch
watch er um do you do you make
assumptions about people and their
anatomies when you meet them or when you
look at them like have you kind of
looked around the room engaged who's
working with what yeah what do you think
about Joe it's okay you don't want to
super big like the common misconception
bigger is not always better
he's [ __ ] right because only so far
you can go so there's no point
right Richard seen a movie in 30 years
[Laughter]
bigger is not always better
no have you guys all compared to see
whose biggest please rub them against
each other
I've seen his many times Richard show me
photos even when I haven't asked he's
really yes
I'm sorry I have I have a few of I
always keep a few photos handy yeah you
don't use them my study it's just I if I
happen to bring it up and someone's like
all right I'm like every now and then a
great angle you ask for him for days
wow they're not confident they won't
send it the big I don't take those blah
blah yeah it's like always lying so you
send back a dirty picture for a dick
picture yeah yeah I always I'm always
like the first one and then I'll be like
okay your turn and then it's like it's
not normalized in the longer room maybe
the picture was taken in a library and
they don't want to get in trouble that's
true well you really know how to close
it out